[Música]
y hoy en directo vamos a washington allí
se encuentra cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal de france 24 con quien
vamos a conversar sobre la retoma de los
diálogos entre eeuu y cuba en asuntos
migratorios pero también del programa
anunciado por el gobierno de joe biden
para que refugiados ucranianos que
cuenten con patrocinadores en territorio
estadounidense puedan ingresar al país
temporalmente
cristóbal que detalles se conocen de las
conversaciones con cuba que fueron
retomadas hoy
si fueron retomadas hace cuatro años no
se hablaban precisamente después de la
administración de donald trump el tema
central fue el número creciente de
cubanos están tratando de entrar en la
frontera sur de eeuu entrando por méxico
se calcula que este número dobló entre
febrero y marzo de este año y
precisamente en este mes fueron 32 mil
500 cubanos que fueron pues se trataron
de pasar esta frontera sur de eeuu al
respecto pues el presidente yo bailén y
también el canciller de eeuu el
secretario de estado antonio blind quien
y alejandro mayor que es precisamente
han viajado esta semana a panamá para
pues comunicarle a las regiones a los
países de la región que por favor
trabajen conjuntamente para evitar el
número creciente de emigrantes que han
llegado a la frontera en esta
conversación sin embargo entre él
el secretario de estado el canciller
adjunto por cuba y los oficiales del
departamento de estado y del
departamento de seguridad nacional
también se trabajó sobre la mesa el tema
del síndrome de la habana y eso preocupa
mucho a eeuu teniendo en cuenta que en
el 2017 se empezaron a reportar estas
enfermedades en los diplomáticos
estadounidenses allá en la habana el
diálogo fue muy abierto se espera seguir
trabajando juntos y trabajando
precisamente para tratar de controlar
este número de cubanos que se están
presentando en la frontera sur de eeuu
cristóbal y en otros temas como
funcionaría el programa sobre refugiados
ucranianos que anunció la administración
de badenes para entrar en vigor la
próxima semana
exactamente entraría en vigor a partir
del lunes y precisamente lo que quiere
habitar la administración de bailén es
que se sigan presentando ucranianos en
esta frontera del sur la administración
de bailén el propio joe biden había
dicho que hace unos días iba eeuu estaba
abierto a recibir más de 100 mil
ucranianos en mil refugiados ucranianos
o cerca de 5 millones de refugiados
ucranianos que han salido de su país a
cuenta de la guerra y pues se calcula
que 15.000 ya estaban tratando de entrar
por la frontera sur de entre méxico y
eeuu y eso lo que quiere evitar el
presidente yo bailé con este programa
este programa se llama uniéndose por
ucrania y lo que va a ser entonces el
departamento de estado y el departamento
de seguridad nacional es a partir del
lunes decirle a los estadounidenses que
quieran patrocinar a ciudadanos
ucranianos que lo podrán hacer iglesias
ciudadanos normales comunes y corrientes
acá en estados unidos y también ongs
podrán patrocinar a los ciudadanos
ucranianos que hayan estado viviendo en
ucrania antes del 11 febrero que cumplan
con los requisitos de seguridad y con
los requisitos de vacunación este
programa durará dos años a los
ucranianos que sean aceptados y pues las
familias estadounidenses tendrán que
asegurarse que cuentan con los recursos
para financiar a estos